every day joe biden is looking more and
more like jimmy carter low poll numbers
soaring gas prices inflation and now a
hostage situation at a u.s embassy in
the middle east the state department is
now confirming an iranian back rebel
group breached into the u.s embassy in
yemen this week and took us government
employees hostage so why now the simple
answer is american weakness our enemies
abroad don't respect joe biden and now
they're testing him we saw it in tehran
doing the carter administration we saw
it in benghazi during the obama
administration and now it's happening
all over again joining me now former
navy seal jackal willing
also the author of
the final spin jaco thanks so much for
joining us thank you for your service
what do you see playing out here
well you just about said it all right
there look in the past few months we've
abandoned equipment to the enemy we've
abandoned weapons to the enemy and we've
abandoned our citizens to the enemy in
afghanistan and we let someone like the
taliban
dictate how we're going to conduct our
withdrawal that's a an awful message to
send to the world no deterrence
whatsoever so things like this hostage
situation unfolding in yemen we got to
start to expect it because the message
from the biden administration is that we
aren't going to do anything about it
you know sir
we still have folks that are still in
afghanistan we still haven't even gotten
all our people home how can we
depend on our president to get our folks
home from this embassy
i don't think anyone's depending on him
to do that i mean this is he the biden
administrative
administration sent the message that the
houthis aren't terrorists this is an
iran back fundamentalist group that uses
child soldiers they shell civilian areas
they put land mines in civilian cities
they execute people they use human
shields this is absolutely a terrorist
group that propagates the slogan death
to america death to israel and there's
no fear so jacob why don't we take that
designation off of them why don't we
remove that
i i can't even fathom a reason why why
that would be removed from them they are
clearly a terrorist group death to
america death to israel that's what
they're doing and by the way
i don't think there's any better proof
than the fact that they just stormed the
american embassy in yemen
you know i got to ask you this before we
go because we can't just talk about this
we got to do something about it what is
it going to take for us to go on the
offense so the world now respects us
again
well you're right key word is offense we
need to go on offense and look at it's
not just these non-state terror groups
we got china's military practicing
bombing american warships with full-size
targets in the desert we got the
russians conducting offensive training
operations in belarus so you've got
russia you've got china you've got the
houthis this type of behavior will grow
because there's no deterrence no fear
and as you said no respect for america
and we need to bring that back by going
on the offense and proving that we are
the strong great america that we always
have been
you know brother i just pray that we get
this under control before there is
attack on the homeland uh that is our
greatest fear thank you so much for your
service jacob
thanks for having me appreciate it
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else